all right so now we go d4 of course mel
slips
all right well this is gonna be
unwittingly a
uh he's like what damn girl
okay now we've really backed ourselves
into a corner here we've really backed
ourselves into a corner
because not only have i allowed queen h4
check but i've also blundered a knight
all right damage control time
[Music]
all right let's go e4
we have an e4 e5 we can play a lot of
different stuff
and we've been playing the danish gambit
almost consistently
uh since we started the speedrun since
we started the speedrun
but i well let's play a vienna because i
mean lively recommended this in his
course
on you know and
and and and i think a lot of people just
want another take on it
and i'm completely uh i i teach this to
some of my students i think the vienna
is a phenomenal opening
uh for people really below 2400
and part of the reason is that people
playing black just don't study this move
and so the reaction is immediately wrong
in many cases bishop c5 is already
inaccurate
now the point of the vienna gambit i'll
talk about this after the game
is that you're trying to improve on the
king's gambit
and you're trying to improve on it by
first developing the knight
seeing how black develops and then
playing f4
and that can give you the power
to meet e takes f4 in a better way it
turns out that bishop c5
does not prevent us from going f4
something which
a lot of people need to realize
a lot of people need to realize
unconventional with a five thank you
very much i really appreciate it
i really appreciate it he takes f4 okay
i'll talk about bishop takes you one of
course of course of course
all right so this is a very hot
button moment very hot button moment
because not to be political but we don't
want to allow queen h4 check
uh queen h4 check is a very bad thing to
allow because you can't go g3 due to f
takes g3
and uh therefore you need to begin
by playing knight f3 that is very very
important not to be controversial
political here
knight f3 is the best move in this
position i don't know if we can all
agree on this
uh but we need to prevent queen h4
d6 hot take right there that is the
ultimate hot take
that is the ultimate hot take
all right so now we go d4 of course
all right well this is gonna be
unwittingly a
uh he's like what damn girl
okay now we've really backed ourselves
into a corner here
we have really backed ourselves into a
corner because not only have i allowed
queen h4 check but i've also blundered a
knight
all right damage control time
so let's also play queen g4 and give up
the queen that's hilarious this is what
fabby's going to play today against that
five
i wasn't supposed to reveal this but
that was a huge accident and
now fabi's gonna be uh i think fabia's
already
already uh suing me in in the supreme
court
all right
so what do we need to do here
well we need to do the immediate damage
control first
we need to figure out what the threat is
and stop the threat at all costs
the threat is queen h4 check we cannot
prevent queen h4 check directly we can
we can but we need to do it in a way in
an elegant way that doesn't ruin our
position
now let's think about about this for a
second let's think about this for a
second
queen h4 check g3 f takes g3
h takes g3 doesn't work because
a the rook is hanging and b the pawn is
hanging
can we make a move such that after queen
h4 g3
fghg both of these pieces are defended
it's not 92 that doesn't defend the rook
guys queen f3
is what we are going to start our
recovery with yes
we're going to go queen to f3 and
prepare to meet queen h4 with g3 so we
can play fghg
bishop takes c3 so he's trying to trade
he's trying to trade uh
peace that's already a little win for us
because that bishop was really really
good thank you kanye v for the tier one
um this bishop was really good now we
need to prioritize development it's very
important
when you blunder a piece we need to
prioritize
immediate development to try to mix
things up so what does that even mean
we're probably going to castle to this
side because we've already ruined our
king side
and logically as you guys are all
indicating
man great to see agreement on something
d take c3 is the fastest way
uh to enable quick development here
to enable quick development here all
right
so g5 g5 attacking or sorry defending
the pawn on f4
but that's another win for us that's
another win for us he's making subtle
mistakes
he's making subtle mistake um
he's making subtle mistakes why because
let's think about this logically
we're gonna castle to this side and if
he castles short he's going to pay the
price for this pawn
so we need to again prioritize immediate
king side our
queen side development we need to get
our king safe so we can start attacking
it doesn't look nice it looks ugly but
we need to get castled asap
so we can attack the king side bishop d2
is the fastest way of castling
i don't give a damn about this pawn on
a2 obviously because we're going to go
b3 and trap the bishop
when you're down a piece you you don't
you can't care about other stuff like
that
all right um
what should we do now i taught you guys
in the previous game
a particular idea this idea but when
there is a pawn chain
attacking the base of the pawn chain is
often the way to go but attacking the
foot of the pawn chain
can also make the whole structure topple
a5 would have been a good idea here
transferring that here it's the same
exact concept but here we attack the
base of the pawn chain
and that's even better by attacking the
base of the pawn chain we
are likely to make the foot of the pawn
chain collapse collapses well
all right and let's play hg5 i know that
he wants bishop to g4
pinning my queen to my rook but we're
gonna sacrifice another exchange here
in order to to make his whole king side
topple all right
so what should we do now how do we get
the most stuff for our king for our for
our rook
all right
queen takes spawn of course we have no
other choice we got to preserve our
queen
when he's going to take my rook we got
to decide what we're going to capture
here what piece are we going to capture
there's something very cool that happens
in this position
there is something very cool that
happens in this position
which is that after g takes f6 his
bishop
is trapped and that's stuff that just
happens as a result of you playing
aggressively trying to find chances
the bishop comes back to h5 we've opened
up the h file so that is defended by our
rook
that's kind of cool that's kind of cool
stuff
so let's see
all right this is uh
this isn't better for white yet if he
plays this correctly
and i gotta say he's not playing it
badly he gives up the bishop for a pawn
okay now what do we do now we need to
act on the fact that we have a pawn on
f6 here that's a very good pawn
that could be an anchor point for some
of our pieces we need to figure out
how to develop in a very precise way
now the question we need to ask here is
what our opponent wants
and let's reason logically is black
likely to castle kingside
no and we would love him to castle
kingside we checkmate him immediately
so he's very likely to castle queenside
and to do that he's going to have to
move his queen to d7
and castle and we need to think about a
way that we could disawait or stop him
from castling queenside
now as many of you guys and i love this
as many of you guys are coming up with
we could get the bishop to g4 but that
has a drawback
could somebody tell me the drawback of
trying to go bishop e2 bishop g4
in order to prevent castling and we will
go g3 bishop h3 that's a better way of
doing it
it's not that it blocks the pawn it's
that he has the move knight e5
covering the g4 square so it's not that
it's slow it's the same number of moves
as this it's only two moves but the
bishop on h3 is going to be far better
protected
uh than a bishop on e2 which could be
prevented from going to g4 by the night
so all this logic all these concrete
thoughts
you've got to have them in order to
appropriately formulate the right
thoughts
in the position all right
and he does go 95 but now we go bishop
h3
all right
now we go bishop h3
yeah so since we're all left anyway
looks like focusing on the speedrun is a
good idea
that's funny
yeah he's not getting his queen out no
he's already in trouble
he's in big trouble because he can't get
his pieces out his pieces are stuck in
molasses
his pieces are stuck in molasses but
he's playing very well i gotta give our
opponent some credit
okay so he's attacking our queen we need
to move our queen
um to a spot where it protects the pawn
we don't want to go queen e3 we don't
want to give this pawn up that that pawn
is a huge
bargaining chip for us so we can go
queen f5 and go queen g5
it doesn't matter i wouldn't go queen f3
though i wouldn't go queen f3
because then he could move he could move
his knight back to e5 and attack our
queen again
so i like the f5 square uh why not queen
g5 because
yeah because maybe he can play h6 there
and attack our queen again there's
queen g5 would have been synonymous i
also like the fact that this builds a
battery
so if he plays something like queen b8 i
don't know why he would play it but if
he does you know we can go queen d7 with
checkmate
so as he's thinking we need to start
thinking about our subsequent actions
and if we start from a general
standpoint
if we start from a general standpoint
um we probably want to open up the
position right we want to open up the
center
because he we know he's paralyzed we
know that if the center were to
magically open
then uh we would be in a lot better
shape now what does it mean for the
center to open
let me give you guys the following
thought experiment if you could capture
one of your own pawns
which pawn would you capture if you
could remove one of your own pawns from
the board which pawn would it be
well it would of course be the e pawn so
paradoxically a lot of you guys are
saying rookie one and e5 but
if you want to sacrifice that pawn why
should you go rookie one first
just freaking go e5 and get the heck rid
of that pun
so that you could then position the rook
on e5 and if he replaces this pawn with
his pawn
you could sacrifice your rook for his
pawn
what you can't do is sacrifice a rook
for your pawn
you have to force him to be the one to
take that pawn
now we are threatening to take rook
takes e5
with a mating attack will he find a
defending defense against this
i don't think one exists we have to play
faster
and he does find a defense now we need
to pile up on this knight what can we do
how do we pile up on this knight
let's keep our eyes zeroed in on the
target here
bingo bishop f4 again we want to take
the knight
blast through the gates of hell here
with rook takes e5
good job guys good good good job
everybody finding the moves love to see
it
what should we do now according to plan
his king's not going very far that's why
we position these pieces here
and now rook d1 check and then our rook
swoops into d7 all right our rook comes
into d7 yeah not to be political but our
rook comes into d7
boom attacking the queen
all right
this queen has to move and the rook
comes into e7
okay
i'm kidding i'm kidding about of being
political
although everything is political now so
it's only a matter of time before rook
d7 becomes political too
queen to a5 okay
how do we how do we do we actually
get stuff done here okay so we should
begin with a check we should begin with
we should begin with rookie 7 check just
to make his king go to f8 if he goes to
d8 we go queen d7 now let me calculate
really quickly
so let me let me see if a very pretty
move is possible although i don't think
it is
okay now we should just win this
normally we should just win this
normally
um and we need to think logically here
about
how we're going to go about this we need
to attack this f7 pawn
but we need to do it in a way where we
pose as many threats as possible
so the queen from d7 doesn't do
it as well as it does from h5
the queen from d7 doesn't do it as well
as it does from h5 and why is that
the reason that is is because this queen
also has a check on h6 and of course a
mate on g7
right so you need to when you have an
idea you need to develop that idea
um and and improve it as much as
possible particularly when you're
attacking
particularly when you're attacking and
guys yeah i know what i'm doing i see
the clock
and i knew this was forced mate i knew
this was forced made i'm not trying to
to be a showman here i want people to be
involved in the process
we're going to pre-move queen g7 so i
can make sure my
all right
all right so he resigns yeah i was
debating the whole chat that's exactly
what i was doing
now this was a very instructive game i
think and i appreciate people being
so engaged again i really really
appreciate it
um
so after bishop c5
the move f4 is often misinterpreted and
misunderstood
because people think this is impossible
due to bishop takes g1
and after rook takes g1 you see the move
quinn h4 check and the sends chills down
your throat
because well this this is you know
this is um this is terrible this is
terrible we have to go here and then
black goes here but
take the bigger picture view here take
the bigger picture of you
and realize that black has only one
piece developed and it's the queen and
that's the one piece you don't want to
develop this early
so as long as white can deal with the
immediate threats white is completely
winning here
look at this queen it's essentially
stranded you can't
trap it immediately but now what you
want to do
you don't even want to take the spawn
you want to blast open the center
as quickly as possible because you have
this window of opportunity
where black hasn't developed any of his
pieces and the queen is in timbuktu
so you you go d4 this position is like
plus six you can check the engines eval
white is completely winning here just
look at this position this is a threat
this is a threat
white's gonna castle quickly the queen
could get trapped the game is completely
over it's it's it's totally crushing
it's totally crushing because black
simply hasn't developed quickly enough
and the center is already open
all right so
[Music]
let's take a look here yeah
um so this move bishop takes g1 is is
not even close
to as good as it looks he takes f4
is also an error he should play d6
that's the best move just keeping the uh
pawn chain alive in the center he takes
up four knight f3 and now we're able to
see why
uh bishop c5 is misplaced because d4 is
going to come with tempo now of course i
made this
genius move um but instead
d4 gives white a phenomenal position
timbuktu is in mali i think
bishop takes f4 uh and white's got the
center
white's got great development now you
can go queen d2 you can castle along
and you can absolutely just you can
enjoy your life you could even castle
short here there's nothing wrong with
that either
but i'm sure that you know this has been
better analyzed
but i made fabby's novelty unfortunately
i'm gonna have to give fabi a call
and and tell him at the last second that
he can't play this i'm so sorry to
everybody i revealed
revealed the high level preparation here
revealing the higher level preparation
all right
so after knight d4
yeah bishop takes d4 queen f3 and
our opponent played very very well but
he started to commit a series of subtle
mistakes
that ultimately led to the situation
being a lot more complicated than it
should have been
okay now what should black have done i
think the simplest approach to playing
black here
is just to prioritize development you
could go queen h4 check that's a good
way to start g3
takes takes queen g4 but this bishop is
uh is black's best piece it's literally
monopolizing the whole center
and by taking on f on c3 he's giving us
a lot of a lot more air to breathe he's
uh
he's accelerating the development of
this bishop and accelerating
most importantly the development of our
king if he played queen h4 before he we
took the knight well no g3 have
g and we could play bishop g2 here
and you know we still are in the game
although yeah this would have been
totally winning as well
uh so this is this is very very bad of
course for y2
but bishop takes d4 isn't bad okay so
takes takes g5 is fine
now again we prioritize development of
our queen side
we get our king to safety this move was
a big waste of time he should have gone
knight f6 or knight c6 would have been a
good move
you know when you're off a piece as i've
said many times
trading is not your top priority your
top priority is to do the same things
that you would do if you weren't up a
piece
that might be the one piece of advice
that i will prioritize over the rest if
you're up a piece
the more similarly you play to a
situation where material was equal the
better
you will not go wrong by playing in
accordance with the material being equal
you shouldn't
try to modify your play too much because
you're up a piece and the same by the
way goes for the end game a lot of
people struggle with end games
because they assume that there are these
special rules
thank you suzuki for the sub that there
are these special rules for playing the
engine and there are you know the king
becomes active but in large part you
still have to calculate variations you
still need peace activity in the middle
game
and so you should not try to isolate
these areas of the game and try to play
too differently
okay so h4 to open the h file
knight f6 hg and here
of course we get lucky that the bishop
is trapped but he found a nice idea but
it just doesn't work
it just doesn't work what should he have
done here i mean maybe he should have
played f6 but at this point we can go e5
and rip open the center
and uh similar stuff happens as it did
in the game
knight f6 hg bishop g4 queen takes f4
um i think levy's now i i didn't get
levi's course of course
of course but i i've heard a lot about
it i i think it's great
um you know and i think he i'm sure he
did a very genuine
and and good job on the analysis
so i you know i recommend the vienna to
some of my
charlie plays the vienna so i i can
highly i can definitely advocate for it
um okay so bishop takes d1 she takes f6
and now the bishop is trapped and i
think the
most important moment is here this is
what makes or breaks the game
now we now have reduced the material
advantage to an exchange
so how did i find g3 what was the key
logic well the logic is simply to
try your best in as much as you can to
put yourself in your opponent's shoes
i know we've we've forgotten how to do
that in real life but
you can still put yourself in your chest
opponent's choose and think well what is
my opponent what would i do if i were
black
well i would probably go queen d7 and
castle uh
because i won't castle short i mean
that's the only thing uh
that you know that's the only thing that
black literally can do
that's the only thing that black
literally can do
uh and
that's where prophylactic thinking comes
from you say
okay if i were playing black hair i play
queen d7 and castle how do i prevent
that if i'm white well
let's consider the drawback of queen d7
and castle ah it puts the queen of the
king on the same diagonal
do we have a light squared bishop we do
can we get it to that diagonal we can
okay so bishop e2 right let me figure
out what's wrong with this move oh he
can go 95 and cover the square
so let's find another way to do that
well we can put the bishop on a square
where it's protected by the rook
and less accessible to the knight 95
bishop h3 knight g6
uh he's desperately trying to thrash
around and
uh and drive my queen away but we merely
increase our
our chocolate and now this movie five we
know that we want to open up the center
but some people
still want to go rookie one that's not a
terrible move but remember
you can sacrifice a piece for one of
your opponent's pawns or pieces
but you can't sacrifice your piece for
your own pawn so you need to do your
best to just give this pawn away
so that you actually have something
belonging to your opponent here which
you can then take
all right so queen c7 we apply more
pressure on the knight
then we take the knight rather than just
taking the pawn
we realize that we have a far faster
pathway to the seventh rank
we go rookie 7 checking out the decisive
move queen h5
why was queen d7 a worse idea than that
because here he could have given us a
check
and after queen c4 he's still sort of
still kicking defending the square
and so queen h5 is just a better way to
get that done because we can also get
the queen into g7
uh you know i appreciate everybody being
so engaged with the speedrun this is
so much fun for me and uh i've got a lot
of other content planned it's not just
going to be the speed run i'm going to
do opening stuff
and uh and there's gonna be lectures and
we're gonna look at games and
there's years of it that that i have
planned just be patient with it
everything will be out on youtube
so yeah thank you this is awesome this
is great to see
[Music]
you